bonsoir à tous voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce samedi
le beau temps avec un b majuscule enfin
les français ont pu profiter du soleil
en ce from les week-ends de mai à des
températures à la hausse et c'est le
sud-ouest qui a battu des records il
faisait 31 degrés aujourd'hui à biarritz
le temps des tornades en revanche aux
états unis au moins sept personnes ont
perdu la vie
le nombre des gars ont été enregistrés
notamment dans l'arkansas
le centre et le sud du pays sont
touchées et ce n'est qu'un début août
rond-point sur le phénomène avec notre
correspondant à la longue
du nouveau dans la sphère fritzl en
autriche mais également des questions la
jeune femme séquestrée violée a
aujourd'hui disculper sa mère seul son
père serait le responsable de cette vie
inimaginable
sur place les enquêteurs semblent
accabler par cette histoire c'est la
tendance consommation de ce samedi 90 %
des français hors est un espace même
parfois minuscules de jardinage malgré
les problèmes pouvoir d'achat nous
dépensons 6 milliards d'euros par an
pour ce loisir
nous verrons comment dans un instant
enfin c'est l'évènement de la soirée sur
france 2 le retour du théâtre en direct
vous avez vos billets pour tailleur pour
dames de georges feydeau mise en scène
bernard murat à la fiche entre autres
emmanuelle devos pierre arditi et
françois berléand
ils seront avec nous tout à l'heure
merci d'être avec nous et j'espère que
vous avez pu enfin profiter du beau
temps aujourd'hui en tout cas il était
auront ils étaient au rendez vous un peu
partout en france comme sur ces images
dans le nord à lille faisait 20 degrés à
paris 23 les toulousains ont pu se
promener sous 25 degrés et à nice la
température était un peu plus douce le
record du jour je vous le disais a été
enregistrée dans le sud-ouest au tour de
biarritz avec 31 degrés des températures
au dessus des normales saisonnières un
samedi sous le soleil à marseille
également dans les calanques
la carte postale du jour est signée
stéphane despinoy et christophe la rocca
ici il n'ya plus qu'à plonger
littéralement sur la carte postale à
sormiou certains auraient bien aimé que
la calanque garde son charme discret
mais aujourd'hui encore elle a été
victime de son succès ça n'est pas
encore l'été bien sûr mais on s'en
approche les 8 degrés ya deux jours
quand je suis parti de rennes et
pleuvait et là on voit la frc royal les
chanceuses qui habitent ici on vient sur
une longueur d'avancé première journée
bain de soleil
non déjà début mars gfr mayumba la
baraque riscle à la baignade 1,3 mais
même en sautillant c'est pas gagné mais
certains s'y précipitent l'eau n'excède
pas les 15 degrés baal est fraîche mais
bon ça va pour un pour un mois de mai ce
début mais c'est cool jusque là ça va
après pour aller plus loin et se baigner
vraiment c'est un peu plus compliqué
mais pour certains on fait ça suffit
l'heure des vacances n'a pas encore
sonné mais beaucoup se préparent déjà au
cliché souvenez nous on a encore à
l'école on veut passer non pas des
partiels bientôt et là on commet déjà
prêt bon bah c'est qu'il peut l'en se
prépare mentalement pour les pour les
partielles pour ceux qui cherchent le
calme il ya la version sportive pour
admirer la calanque ils n'ont pas hésité
à prendre un peu de hauteur
maintenant les partis de bonne heure qui
on a fait de belles escalade ou
traversait c'est comment jacques e
la traversée d'une extrême bec de
sormiou quand vous passez au ras de
l'eau on tourne derrière est magnifique
le paysage est magnifique c'est seuil 10
si quelques-uns tire sur la corde
d'autres pointent qui manque chez moi
quant à lui mis au total et le pastis
l'eau est peut-être un peu fraîche mais
très franchement un samedi dans ce petit
camp le paradis il ya de quoi faire des
jaloux
voilà pour le beau temps dans
l'actualité à l'étranger c'est la
période des tornades aux états unis
elles touchent comme souvent le centre
et le sud du pays près d'une vingtaine
d'épisodes ont été enregistrés dans les
états de l'arkansas de l'oklahoma et du
missouri
les dégâts matériels sont toujours aussi
impressionnants et le bilan est déjà de
sept morts le point richard binet sur la
route qui mène à gladstone dans l'état
du missouri
le ciel s'est brusquement obscurci les
témoins ont alors vu un nuage noir
parcouru des clercs puis une masse
sombre une sorte de serpent animé par
des vents soufflant à plus de 160 km
heure
la tornade a traversé gladstone amour en
tout sur son passage
balayant les maisons comme des châteaux
de cartes ce matin les habitants mesurer
l'étendue des dégâts
ils racontaient leur peur je me suis
réfugié son étal et je me suis même
boîte sur la tête en ce moment là la
corde vert a explosé et puis j'ai
entendu la porte du garage s'excusait à
son tour j'étais terrifiée je me suis
allongé le long d'une clôture j'ai
protégé ma tête et je me suis dit mon
heure est arrivée seigneur en moins de
24 heures plus de 20 tornades ont
parcouru le centre et le sud est des
états unis
et c'est presque un miracle que leur
passage en effet que cette victime car
les cyclones sont de plus en plus
violents en début de semaine les vents
dépasser les 180 km/heure des véhicules
ont été projetés dans les airs des
toitures arrachées des structures
d'acier totalement détruite
nous entrons dans le début de l'activité
cyclonique mai et juin sont
traditionnellement les mois les plus
sévères le métérologue s'inquiète
également de l'augmentation de la
fréquence des tornades
l'an dernier à la même époque il en
avait compté 517 plus de 700 cette année
dérèglement climatique ou aller à
statistiques
il est sans doute trop tôt pour le dire
mais les américains restent vigilants
alors ce phénomène on sait n'est pas
nouveau on va prendre la direction de
washington pour tenter d'y voir un peu
plus clair avec un jalon bonsoir alain l
amérique est habitué à ces tornades mais
elles sont apparemment de plus en plus
nombreuses
oui de plus en plus fréquentes
effectivement dans les années 80 il y en
avait entre 700 et 800 par an maintenant
on est largement autour de 1200 c'est à
dire une augmentation de 50%
et puis il ya aussi l'étalement sur
l'année avant s'était concentrée sur
avril mai et juin en gros maintenant il
y en a tout le temps y en a même en
hiver
cet hiver par exemple on en a eu 136 en
janvier 232 en février alors que la
moyenne normale est respectivement de 34
et 25 voiliers ça n'a plus rien à voir
et puis aussi des tornades un peu
partout auparavant s'étaient concentrés
sur ce qu'on appelle le couloir des
tornades qui va du du texas jusqu'aux
grands lacs c'est à dire en gros le
middle-west avec ses grandes plaines et
bien maintenant il y en a partout on en
a même eu ici à washington pour la
première fois c'était du jamais vu
atlanta a été dévastée par une tornade
il ya quelques semaines est en ce moment
même on a une alerte rouge qui va de la
nouvelle orléans jusqu'à atlanta une
nouvelle fois alors il ya encore un
autre phénomène sait les dégâts causés
les dégâts sont très impressionnants
mais en réalité ces tornades ne sont pas
plus meurtrières qu'avant même s'il ya
eu sept morts aujourd'hui s'il ya eu 17
morts il ya quelques jours on oublie
vite le passé on oublie qu'en 1925 une
seule thormann une seule tornades avait
fait 6 189 morts dans le missouri
merci alain pour toutes ces précisions
au chili cette fois d'autres images
spectaculaires celle d'un volcan en
éruption pas de victimes pour le moment
et plusieurs milliers de personnes de la
région située dans le sud du pays ont dû
quitter leur domicile images commentées
par gilles rabin au chili il ya plus de
deux mille volcan et on s'est tous des
éruptions volcaniques pourtant personne
ne pensait voir se réveiller le shuttle
un volcan de patagonie qui dort depuis
plus de neuf mille ans la ville en
contrebas est noyé sous une mer de
cendre qui recouvre tout visibilité très
réduite réserves d'eau polluée les
autorités font distribuer de l'eau
potable ainsi que des masques
les écoles ont été fermées les femmes
enceintes les mères de jeunes enfants et
les enfants
1500 personnes au total ont été évacuées
préventivement
nous ne savons pas si nous partons pour
toujours ou si nous reviendront un jour
nous ne savons pas les autorités ont
décidé d'évacuer les habitants par la
mère une voie plus sûr et plus rapide
on s'attend en effet à une éruption
majeure qu'une soixantaine de secousses
et de petits séismes en 24 heures semble
annoncer
l'alerté rouge a été donné j'appelle la
population à rester calme et à suivre
les instructions des autorités
comme toujours certains refusent
catégoriquement de quitter leur maison
non non je m'en remets à dieu omnium
tous sont prêts à partir dès que l'ordre
tombera en sachant qu'ils ne reviendront
peut-être jamais
dans l'eure vivent en france cette
information sans conséquence grave mais
a souligné la terre a tremblé
aujourd'hui dans les hautes pyrénées
dans la région tarbes et de bagnères de
bigorre une secousse de magnitude 4 sur
l'échelle de richter qui n'a fait aucun
dégât dans l'actuelle est également de
ce samedi à nice des coups de feu ont
été échangés ce matin entre deux hommes
et une patrouille de police les deux
individus ont été surpris alors qu'il
venait de braquer une supérette
un policier a été blessé ainsi qu'une
femme touchée par une balle perdue sur
place nathalie jourdan olivier
prudemment 11h30 ce matin deux hommes
casqués descendre de leur moto armes
automatiques au point il pénètre dans
cette épicerie niçoise dans le magasin
le patron des employés des clients et
des enfants emma prend-il avec le
revolver et quand j'ai vu ça j'ai donné
tous les deux braqueurs s'empare de la
caisse
il saute sur leur moto et démarre en
trombe ils chutent une cinquantaine de
mètres plus loin continuent leur fuite
d'abord en courant puis en marchant sans
s'apercevoir qu'ils sont suivis deux
hommes sont à leurs trousses et
communique avec la police par téléphone
portable et leurs poursuivants l'aleps
drula jusqu'à à bellevue et c'est là
qu'arrive est un flic en civil en moto
et on les a indiqué que c'était les deux
qui marchait qu'elle fait le coup et
le flic appelez-la renfort et d
encercler la fihg elle a commencé une
fusillade en pleine rue à l'heure du
déjeuner les riverains sont au balcon
ils ont crié arrêté a été en dire elle
est content on commence à partir pour
moi j'ai fait remarquer hier un policier
touché une balle dans le bras une autre
dévié par son gilet pare-balles le
blesse légèrement au ventre la fusillade
continue une balle perdue atteinte dame
de 93 ans au mollet la blessure est
superficiel les braqueurs sont
finalement neutralisées ils sont en
garde à vue la police à récupérer leur
butin moins de 5000 euros renault
maintenant tu ça va faire au mexique
dans laquelle une jeune française de 33
ans est impliquée elle a été je vous le
rappelle qu'on années là-bas 96 années
de prison pour enlèvements et ça alors
qu'elle clame toujours son innocence la
jeune femme et ses parents en appellent
désormais au président sarkozy
l à palo patrie bullestorm depuis deux
ans et demi et son interpellation
spectaculaire au mexique florence cassez
clame son innocence il ya une semaine
elle a pourtant été condamnée à 96 ans
de prison pour avoir participé à
plusieurs enlèvements
son compagnon de l'époque un mexicain
aurait avoué mais jointe au téléphone
florence cassez elle nie tout en bloc
cette jeune femme originaire du nord
demandent aux autorités françaises
d'intervenir pour rompre son isolement
je survis je survis et je me bats et je
me bats parce que je suis innocente et
c'est la seule fort que j'ai aujourd'hui
ce matin ses proches ont d'ailleurs
officiellement réclamé l'aide de nicolas
sarkozy il faut qu'on ait un coup de
main deux du gouvernement français il
faut qu'on ait une une aide médiatique
pour pouvoir la faire sortir de ce tour
un nouvel avocat français cette fois a
été saisie de la sphère dans un des
lieux à peu près de 6 à lui moi elle va
repasser devant une juridiction d'appel
au mexique
on va refaire un travail avec son avocat
sur place là bas au mexique et se battre
en tout état de cause elle pourra
demander à être transféré en france pour
purger sa peine il y a une semaine la
sphère été révélé on avait du mal à y
croire comment un homme at il pu
séquestrer pendant 24 ans une partie des
membres de sa famille les informations
les lieux révèle progressivement
l'ampleur du drame vécu par sa fille qui
aujourd'hui a souhaité disculper sa mère
faisons ce soir un point sur les
questions de cette affaire avec lionel
feierstein les enquêteurs eux-mêmes ne
supporte plus d'y descendre
cela fait plus d'une semaine qu'ils
travaillent dans cette cave à
l'atmosphère oppressante une prison
construite par josef fritzl pour sa
fille elisabeth
elle y a vécu 24 ans dans quelles
conditions
c'est ce qu'ils essayent de comprendre
ce réduit d'un mètre soixante dix de
haut n'était au départ composé que d'une
seule pièce pendant les six premiers
mois de sa captivité
elisabeth est attaché à un poteau puis à
une corde
son père la viola maintes reprises elle
aura sept enfants de cette union
incestueuse dont un mourra peu après sa
naissance pour qu'elle ne s'évadent pas
josef fritzl affirme avoir piégé la cave
avec un dispositif au gaz at il agi seul
oui affirme sa fille aux enquêteurs
selon elle sa mère rose marie n'était
pas au courant
seul son père lui aurait apporté
vêtements et nourriture
les locataires du premier étage se
souviennent du comportement étrange de
josef fritzl passe cela faisait partie
du règlement clp temps il me l'a souvent
répété
j'avais interdiction de me rendre dans
la cave et dans le jardin
c'était très clair c'est pareil pour les
photos c'est est formellement interdit
mais alors comment expliquer ces images
josef fritzl en vacances plusieurs jours
en thaïlande puis à chypre pendant ce
temps qui s'occupait de sa fille de ses
enfants
des enquêteurs cherchent à comprendre
josef fritzl est il impliqué dans
d'autres affaires
sans doute le père d'elizabeth aurait
été condamné pour plusieurs affaires de
viol à la fin des années 60 ces faits
selon la loi autrichienne ne figure plus
sur son casier judiciaire
les enquêteurs cherchent également à
savoir si josef fritzl est impliqué dans
le meurtre en 1986 de cette jeune fille
de 17 ans l'homme tenait une pension de
famille près de l'endroit où le corps de
martin à posh a été retrouvé josef
fritzl n'a sûrement pas livré tous ses
secrets
en grande bretagne gordon brown entend
tirer les leçons de la défaite
historique enregistrée hier par ses
troupes lors des élections municipales
le premier ministre qui avait lorsqu'il
a pris les rênes du pouvoir à tony blair
une avance de 11 points dans les
enquêtes d'opinion sur les conservateurs
la situation s'est donc inversée et un
homme
on a profité c'est le nouveau maire de
l'ong l'iconoclaste boris johnson sur
place maryse burgot et laurent des bois
derrière cette révolutionnaire façade de
la mairie de londres boris johnson
s'installe sobre signature cet
après-midi pour accepter le poste de
maire l'egypte copains et plaisanteries
et nous voici sous la plus haute couche
de ce merveilleux omnium ex-journaliste
suscite l'hilarité de la salle un oignon
donc que le maire travailliste sortant
ken livingstone a perdu cette nuit avec
circulaire les conservateurs vu bill
l'arrivée de ce personnage extravagant à
la tête de la capitale
elle le coup de grâce pour une gauche
britannique
laminée lors de ces élections et pour
les caricaturistes ce nouveau maire
c'est du pain bénit cheveux en bataille
humour de potache et accents un rien
populiste boris johnson ratisse large
les londoniens ont majoritairement
choisi pour l'heure très cosmopolite
capitale un maire qui a dû s'excuser
pour quelques rares blague xénophobe
bien sûr il a déjà cessé d'animer cette
émission de satire politique craindre un
workout à bourgogne lieu désormais l'ex
journaliste gérera le budget de la plus
grosse capitales d'europe
l'anticonformiste boris johnson
s'installe donc dans cet immeuble tout
si fantasque que lui s'il réussit son
mandat dans cette mairie ce sera un
formidable tremplin pour les
conservateurs qui espère bien reprendre
le pouvoir lors des prochaines
législatives
on revient en france avec le ministre de
l'éducation xavier darcos qui était
devant la pep l'association des parents
d'élèves réunis aujourd'hui à clermont
ferrand
il a rappelé qu'il voulait restaurer la
place de la famille à l'école et
confirmé qu'il allait mettre en place le
service minimum d'accueil dans les
écoles et cela dans la perspective du
mouvement de grève prévu le 15 mai
prochain une disposition critiquée par
les syndicats
on les écoute ne s'agit pas du tout
d'une démarche idéologique d'ailleurs
cette affaire
j'ai pas du tout jouer les briseurs de
grève ou conseille ces gens veulent
faire grève qu'ils fassent grève mais
j'ai tout simplement dans le service aux
familles qui n'ont pas les moyens de
garder leur enfant je le répète il n'y a
aucune raison que des parents et de la
double peine 1 g par classe de geneviève
se répandent enfants sur les bras
le premier ni celui dont on passe
préoccuper des sondages qui sont en
baisse ces derniers jours il ne pense
qu'à une chose les réformes des réformes
qu'il faudra définitivement mettre en
place dans un climat économique
difficile un homme le lui a rappelé lors
de son séjour aux états unis c'est le
directeur général du fmi dominique
strauss kahn reportage françoise david
et les nuques poignée de main
chaleureuse entre henry paulson
secrétaire américain au trésor et
françois fillon face à la crise
américaine et ses répercussions sur
l'économie européenne et notamment
françaises les deux hommes sont tombés
d'accord pour plus de transparence et de
coordination
car le premier ministre français en est
maintenant convaincu la france subira
l'impact de la crise outre-atlantique
nous avons revu à la baisse les
prévisions de croissance pour la france
en 2008 que le premier trimestre sera
bon pouvoir même meilleur qu'attendu
en revanche le deuxième trimestre
devrait être plus difficile avec un
premier impact du choc conjoncturel
international françois fillon apparaît
donc soucieux et les français semblent
partager son opinion selon un sondage
csa réalisé pour le magazine marianne
62% d'entre eux redoutent une grave
crise ici la fin du quinquennat
ils ne sont que 30 % à éprouver plus
d'optimisme
et le pessimisme des français rejoint
d'ailleurs celui du directeur du fonds
monétaire international dominique
strauss kahn depuis que les bruits de
fond que vous venez ça à moi et vous les
européens ont prouvé qu'elles étaient un
peu
et si liste déjà et l'allemagne et
l'espagne ont réajusté leurs propres
prévisions à la baisse
donc je pense qu'en réalité pression du
franc sont malheureusement je dirais les
bonnes parce que c'est vrai qu'elles
sont pas très forte alors que le tandem
sarkozy fillon va franchir le cap d'une
année au pouvoir
les nuages économique assombri l'avenir
le feuilleton 68 c'était hier continue
nous vous disions hier que la france
s'ennuyer et voilà qu'elle va se
révolter
tout commence le 3 mai avec l'
occupation de la sorbonne l'histoire en
images avec christophe airaud 3 mai 68
au matin la cour de la sorbonne était
très calme c'est une centaine
d'étudiants à tenir meeting à l'appel de
l'unef et du mouvement du 22 mars et
dans l'après midi sous la menace de
l'extrême droite qui guette à
l'extérieur la situation se tend
pour le recteur jean roche la décision
s'impose il faut évacuer la sorbonne et
la police entre dans la cour de la forme
c'est du jamais vu les forces de l'ordre
pénètre dans l'université
pour ce face à face deux personnages
daniel cohn bendit le leader étudiant et
maurice grimaud préfet de police est
responsable du maintien de l'ordre
quarante ans plus tard pour la première
fois il se rend compte le préfet grimoux
c'est l'homme grâce à kimi 68 ne fut pas
meurtrier l'homme qui déclare à l'époque
frappé un homme à terre c'est se frapper
soi même explication du 3 mai par
maurice grimaud charbonneau 3 pourquoi
ya violence par une maladresse votre
part on avait évoqué son problème sans
chant matraquage sortis normalement
la preuve avec h retirait cet effet mais
sans celui des contrôles d'identité des
arrestations et en réaction des
barricades les premiers affrontements le
slogan libérez nos camarades fusent et
personne pour réveiller le chef de
l'état de bol qui dormait et que
personne n'a voulu réveiller
incroyable et c'est là ça aussi c'est la
france de l'époque qui se passe quand
même quelque chose il a raison depuis la
commune un pas vu ça dans paris on peut
quand même d'affronter au président du
président il se passe quelque chose
alors demain matin revenez demain matin
quarante ans après l'entretien est très
chaleureux car depuis 40 ans le respect
est mutuel grimont et papon c'est pas la
même chose pour être court et c2 préfet
de police de paris
donc ça veut dire que préfet de policé
préfet de police est pas la même chose
j'observe je me flux du torse c'est pas
une crémerie j'observerai comme extrême
atterré le parcours de daniel de plus ça
je trouve ça assez remarquable bas qui
sera peut-être leur unique rencontre
mais ces deux personnages prouve qu'il
restera toujours un héritage à mai 68 et
vous pouvez suivre l'ensemble de cet
entretien entre daniel cohn-bendit et
l'ancien préfet grimaud dans le magazine
le point
cette semaine c'est devenu un rendez
vous des plus classiques la tribu des
teufeurs s'est donné rendez vous cette
fois accru ses villages en eure-et-loir
ils seront près de 30000 cette nuit à
l'occasion du teknival rendez vous
autoriser et encadrer et qui se déroule
jusqu'à à demain plus calme le jardin
est un petit coin de paradis pour de
nombreux français je vous le disais en
titre 90% d'entre nous se sont aménagés
chez eux un espace plus ou moins grand
de jardinage
autre chiffre impressionnant ce marché
représente 6 milliards d'euros par an
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
magasins spécialisés fleurissent
repartage aujourd'hui en alsace téphany
la fuente et antje stahlschmidt dès les
premiers rayons printaniers c'est une
nouvelle pièce qui apparaît aux abords
de la maison car aujourd'hui peyratte
ces jardins sont devenus de véritables
salon d'été
alors avant d'installer la pergola et le
barbecue première étape plantes et
arbres et fleurs deux principes un se
cacher un peu des voisins nous qui un
certain nombre de plantes arbustives
comme les bambous les lilas etc
et puis après des fleurs tout court que
ce soit les pivoines des rhododendrons
les camélias etc
pour avoir de la fleur
après un début de printemps plus que
gris ce week-end prolongé et ensoleillé
est une aubaine pour les jardineries
on attend 30 à 40 % de clients de plus
qu'un week-end normal
pétunia rosiers géraniums lauriers les
jardiniers amateurs choisissent leurs
fleurs un peu comme les peintres les
couleurs de leur palais pour marier les
couleurs ont marre il est fort mon mail
d écran de verre de différentes
profondeurs si vous voulez pour faire un
espèce de décor et on est bien s'y
retrouver dans les journées de beau
temps
je mets tous qui est-il orange orange et
aux couleurs très chaudes en fait
conforme à la france on appelle soleil
mais bon on essaye long terme fontaine
et autres accessoires s'étend sur 1 5e
des 13 mille mètres carrés de ce magasin
depuis cinq ans la décoration de jardin
est en plein essor
et comme dans la mode à chaque saison sa
collection et allegri les noirs les
couleurs très tendance très moderne et
après vous avez les couleurs fuchsia
vert anis pour pour le peps au premier
temps quelques conseils avant de se
lancer histoire de ne pas se tromper car
jardiner c'est aussi dépensé budget
moyen de 20 euros pour un balcon à plus
de 500 euros pour un vaste jardin
demain débuteront dès discussions entre
deux émissaires du dalaï lama et des
responsables chinois sur la crise au
tibet à shenzhen dans le sud du pays de
son côté la flamme olympique
elle est en terrain conquis à macao elle
a été acclamée dans cette file
rétrocédée à la chine en 99 et que l'on
a a pris pour habitude d'appeler l'enfer
du jeu à pékin
en tout cas on se prépare à accueillir
des dizaines de milliers spectateurs
pour les jeux et la question du moment
et comment loger toute cette population
il y a les hôtels bien sûr mais aussi
d'autres moyens reportage sur place
pascal golomer et si l'énergie home
depuis son ouverture il ya un an ils
accueillent plutôt les hommes et les
femmes d'affaires
mais en août prochain ce grand hôtel de
pékin change de clientèle bienvenue au
public des jeux olympiques tant attendu
l'hôtel affiche presque complet
les tour opérateurs ont déjà réservé les
7000 chambres haut de gamme disponibles
en ville mais le confort 5 étoiles fin
pris ce prix commencent à 7 mm be ce qui
veut dire que près de 700 euros voilà
c'est non c'est normal et c'est jacques
ont pas rêver d autres hôtels j'ai
entendu parler qu'ils ont commencé à
vendre 9 900 euros ou ou 1000 euros nous
on reste normal
normal c'est tout de même 50% de plus
que le prix habituel ceux qui préfèrent
éviter les hôtels et leurs tarifs
mirobolants peuvent se tourner vers les
chambres d'hôtes un concept en pleine
expansion pour ces jeux olympiques
jacob cook propose via son site internet
des séjours chez l'habitant
madame yuan par exemple et son
appartement très spacieux bien au-dessus
de la moyenne pékinoise six chambres sur
trois étages jacob s'occupe de tout ils
fixent eux mêmes le prix 750 euros par
semaine et par personne est promis
pas de mauvaise surprise on doit être en
bon état temps avec tout ce qu'on forme
un pays occidental
d'autres doivent parler avec la langue
de leurs locataires cas cela nous nous
assurons aussi que s'ils font ça c'est
avant tout parce qu'ils sont heureux
d'accueillir des étrangers
mais si vous souhaitez vraiment vivre à
la pékinoise
alors c'est chez monsieur you et son
épouse qui peut aller sonner c'est à 20
minutes à pied du stade olympique
ce couple de retraités mais sa chambre
d'amis à disposition des visiteurs
étrangers
la ville a recruté 1 6000 familles
d'accueil qui loueront leur chambre 50
euros la nuit madame joue elle ne veut
pas d'argent car c'est pour la bonne
cause
nos invités vont pouvoir constater par
eux-mêmes l'amélioration de la vie des
chinois depuis la politique de réforme
et d'ouverture du pays comme cela nous
pourrions vraiment réduire la distance
qui sépare le peuple chinois relève
applaudi avec trois cent mille étrangers
attendus à pékin pendant les jeux
toutes les solutions de logement seront
les bienvenus même si peu de lauwers et
montreront aussi généreux que nos amis
retraités la page aux sports de ce
samedi avec du football est tout d'abord
lyon qui ne sera pas sacré champion ce
week-end les lyonnais ont été tenus en
échec a admis aujourd'hui le score 0 à 0
et cela malgré de belles occasions de
part et d'autre comme vous le voyez sur
ces images
à noter que bordeaux joue demain
marseille et à un quart d'heure de la
fin en maths classement le paris saint
germain a ouvert le score un but à 0
face à toulouse but de bernard mendy il
reste 15 minutes de jeu autre image et
autres résultats de football en
angleterre cette fois définitivement
tout va bien pour manchester united
après sa qualification pour la finale de
la ligue des champions les red devils se
sont rapprochés du titre de champion une
première
lee après leur victoire 4 1 face à west
ham
avec à la clé un doublé de cristiano
ronaldo
pendant tout le week-end la ville de
montpellier via leurs sportifs
passionnés de roller vtt ou encore de
wakeboard se sont donné rendez vous au
festival international des sports
extrêmes et cette année la discipline
tendance c'est le bmx sur place hélène
verne et frédéric bibal 540 ou encore
les riders qui deux filles règles de la
gravité et pour cette 12e édition du
festival des trois ex cannes où le
public salue tous qu'il enchaînera ses
excellents le site est superbe
montpellier on connaissait pas forcément
fin pas ce côté là de la ville le bmx
c'est le nom dans ce port apparu dans
les années 70 aux etats unis un tout
petit vélo un casque et une bonne dose
de courage
les meilleurs sont américains ou anglais
mais les français travaillent dur pour
être reconnu comme tout sport prendre du
plaisir simplement
jusqu'à cinq heures par jour
d'entraînement une discipline
aujourd'hui étroitement associée à une
allure couleurs et pantalon si un mode
de vie et ça passe pour les vêtements ça
passe par la musique même par des fois
la coupe de cheveux ou par n'importe
quel truc qui peut devenir le style et
l'originalité des figures comme en hip
hop et à ce jeu-là matthias dandois est
actuellement le meilleur au monde
si le but c'est d'être le plus original
possible d'aborder des figures se
perfusion la france compte vingt-cinq
mille pratique en bmx une discipline qui
deviendra olympique pour la première
fois cette année à pic
le théâtre vient en direct ce soir sur
france 2 c'est dans quelques minutes
avant de retrouver trois des comédiens
de la troupe qui seront sur scène un
extrait de ce qui vous attend
tailleur pour dames c'est du feydeau mis
en scène par bernard murat
c'est le niveau de cette femme où la
pause et cette rave et je suis conquis
je suis madame madame madame aux neuf
femmes
et on retrouve donc trois des membres de
la troupe de bernard murat en duplex du
théâtre edouard vii à paris avec nous
emmanuelle devos françois berléand et
pierre arditi bonsoir à vous honneur aux
dames
emmanuelle devos merci d'être avec nous
c'est une première pour vous ce rendez
vous en direct à la télévision première
même de jouer c'est donc pour moi c'est
vraiment une grande première
alors vous dites que cette pièce est
tellement tellement drôle que vous avez
peur d'avoir un fou rire sur scène c'est
ça vous avez vu et partenaires surtout
celui ci il est extrêmement brillant et
drôle donc c'est très difficile par
moments de résister jusqu'ici j'ai bien
tenu donc j'espère que ce soir ça va ça
va continuer alors justement votre
partenaire pierre arditi c'est quand
même pas mal de jouer devant une salle
de plusieurs millions de téléspectateurs
est ce que finalement ça va changer
quelque chose pour vous pas pas dans un
petit coin de la tête ça change
forcément parce que on a beau se dire
qu'on va après tout on joue au théâtre
et que c'est un acte normal d'abord ça
n'est pas un acte normal puisque c'est
en direct puisque cette pièce est
remonté spécialement pour france
télévisions et puis c'est vrai que dans
un petit coin de la tête il ya sans
doute quelques millions de personnes qui
vont regarder tous en même temps mais il
faut pas y penser faut faut jouer il
faut avoir envie venus s'amuser d'amuser
les gens et puis si on joue bien pour
les gens qui sont dans la salle ce soir
on jouera bien pour les gens qui
regardent la télévision
alors françois berléand il faut juste
rappeler que cela fait tout de même six
semaines que vous travaillez sur cette
pièce six semaines de répétitions je
crois six semaines de répétitions tous
les jours c'est mécanique implacable
feydeau c'est très très drôle mais c'est
ça demande beaucoup de beaucoup
d'énergie de la part de tout le monde
notamment de pierre et puis
effectivement la très très peur du fou
rire moi il se trouve que j'ai de la
chance de jouer un personnage qui avait
tout le temps donc si j'ai un fou rire
ça ne se verra pas trop quoi que je ne
sais pas quoi que pierre arditi un mood
cette intrigue
un vaudeville et puis toujours une
histoire d'adultère chez feydeau oui
enfin oui toujours une histoire de
quiproquo ou un cetain c'est un médecin
qui passent la nuit dehors parce qu'ils
pensaient retrouver une femme qui ne
retrouvera pas donc il retrouve au fond
il n'est coupable de rien et quand il
revient chez lui il se fait évidemment
piégé par sa femme auquel il est obligé
de commencer par faire un petit mensonge
et petit à petit mais la main dans un
engrenage dans l'engrenage du mensonge
qui devient de plus en plus énorme
évidemment il est dans une spirale
infernale avec des gens qui tissent et
qui se tournent autour de lui et puis on
arrive à des sommets de surréalisme et
de rires d'ailleurs de et de fous rires
mais ce serait bien assis à des fous
rires c'est très très bien j'espère que
c'est les gens qui vont les avoirs les
fous rires mais c'est un c'est un
vaudeville flamboyant comme on les aime
je crois et puis ces faits d'eau poiret
il faut pas oublier ça il ya deux
auteurs qui se complètent à un siècle
d'intervalle et je crois que le mariage
est absolument magnifique dernier mot de
bernard murat il est un peu stressé
c'est torcy mais bernard murat il va se
regarder à travers nous il va revoir sa
première mise en scène car c'était sa
première mise en scène ya exactement 23
ans qui a été un triomphe
je pense qu'il a encore évolué dans sa
manière de travailler il a une équipe
extraordinaire qui sera au moins aussi
bonne que celle de la création
et puis nous a entouré comme une mère
poule comme toujours à long nez on va
essayer d'être heureux avec lui et
o'shea pour lui et cela va très bien se
passer bien on va rire j'en suis sûr
beaucoup ce soir et puis vous ne serez
pas que tous les trois sur scène on
pense bien sûr à marthe villalonga chloé
lambert et laurent gamelon on vous
retrouve donc dans quelques minutes
c'est la 18e journée internationale de
la liberté de la presse aujourd'hui
reporters sans frontières publie cette
année encore un album photo consacré
cette année au travail de bettina rheims
les recettes des ventes seront
intégralement reversés à l'organisation
aujourd'hui encore près de 130
journalistes à travers le monde sont
toujours détenus avant de terminer le
journal on se quitte sur ces images
c'est du beau temps un peu partout en
france
un samedi au soleil des températures qui
ont atteint jusqu'à 32
et dans le sud ouest du pays on fera le
point météo dans un instant sur la
journée de demain avec isabelle martinez
voilà pour l'essentiel de l'actualité de
ce samedi merci d'être fidèle à l'info
sur france 2 la météo dont puis dès
20h50 le grand direct du soir avec le
théâtre est tailleur pour dames demain
dès midi france de foot denis balbir on
se retrouve à 13 heures pour
l'information l'invité de la page
politique sur à jack lang
je vous souhaite une très belle soirée
au théâtre bien sûr
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr